madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
et Messieurs mes chers collègues le
partage de la valeur est un facteur
essentiel d'attractivité des entreprises
de valorisation de justice sociale et de
cohésion sociale le 10 février dernier
après avoir mené des négociations de
plusieurs mois des négociations
difficiles mais constructives
l'intégralité des partenaires sociaux à
une exception près ont trouvé un accord
un accord poursuivant un but précis la
distribution plus juste des richesses
produites par les entreprises dans ce
contexte le Gouvernement a souhaité
aller plus loin sur le sujet en donnant
une assise législative à cette avancée
significative via le projet de loi
visant à transposer la Cour nationale
interprofessionnelle sur la valeur sur
le partage de la valeur au sein de
l'entreprise ce projet de loi s'articule
donc autour de quatre objectifs
renforcer le dialogue social sur les
classifications faciliter la
généralisation des dispositifs de
partage de la valeur
la mise en place des dispositifs de
partage de la valeur et enfin développer
l'actionnariat salarié des notions
essentielles au principe de justice
sociale que vous savez chères aux
démocrates et que plusieurs lois visant
à simplifier renforcer les dispositifs
de partage de la valeur dans les
entreprises sont venues conforter ces
dernières années bien que ce projet de
loi est précisément pour objet d'assurer
cohérence et fidélité aux mesures
convenues dans la nuit il apparaît
surprenant de constater la volonté
persistant des oppositions d'éloigner le
texte de sa focation originelle et il
est de même difficile de comprendre la
motivation qui sous-entend cette
démarche chers collègues si nous
procédons de la sorte quel serait demain
la valeur d'un accord national
interprofessionnel quel poids aurait la
parole d'une organisation syndicale ou
patronale s'ils savent que le partement
le Parlement peut détricoter ce qu'ils
ont négocié avec leur père enfin quelle
lég aurions-nous à dévoyé et détourner
de son sens initial un accord ayant été
signé entre professionnels après
d'apprent négociation quand il s'agit
d'une transposition ce n'est pas là
notre rôle allez évident certains
amendements seraient susceptibles
d'altérer d'intégrité et l'esprit de ce
texte et remettraient en question
l'équilibre trouvé par les partenaires
sociaux à l'inverse je tiens à rappeler
ici que l'ensemble des amendements
portés par les démocrates ont fait
l'objet d'une négociation avec ces
derniers cet accord approuvé par
l'ensemble de l'arc républicain
représente un véritable compromis entre
les besoins des salariés et les défis
auxquels sont constamment confrontés des
employeurs et j'aimerais souligner ici
que si la CGT n'a pas signé l'accord
elle n'a jamais remis en question le
bien-fondé de Lagny en appelant à voter
contre ce projet de loi
à l'inverse l'intitulé de certaines
oppositions reflètent bien une posture
idéologique qui sent le primé sur une
analyse approfondie et objective des
mesures contenues dans l'année certaines
de vos prises de position de parole en
commission traduisent une réflexion dont
je ne sais si elle tient de la
malhonnêteté ou de la méconnaissance de
ce qui est vraiment une entreprise une
entreprise elle se fonde initialement
sur une idée sur un projet sur des
espérances le but premier de l'immense
majorité des chefs d'entreprise n'est
pas d'exploiter leurs salariés mais de
faire marcher leur entreprise de donner
une concrétule à leurs idées sans la
présence des employeurs
ignorez tout simplement pas
d'entreprises donc pas de salarié nul
l'entreprise ne saurait fonctionner sans
la présence et sans l'investissement des
salariés cela peut sembler candide mais
c'est une interdépendance bien plus
réelle et concrète que la vision
manichéenne que certains d'entre vous
souhaitent plaquer sur le monde du
travail l'accord transposé va bien
prendre en considération
cet équilibre nécessaire et mettant
relief les vertus du dialogue social au
regard de l'importance fondamentale
qu'il revêt le groupe démocrate et
évidemment favorable à ce projet de loi
je vous remercie